Leia's Campbell knows firsthand of being
held he would never hold anybody but he
was probably held a few times last night
the Jags defensive end joining us on the
program how are you class I'm doing
pretty good you know those goods in a
big way okay cuz they call holding on
every single play in your opinion
they're pretty much doing you know I
play I'm probably probably every play
but I know the only call the party you
know ten percent of the time is that are
they calling it too many too often yeah
but there's no flow to the game here I
mean do you it's almost like I expect a
penalty a flag to be thrown whenever
there is any long play there was like
it's just I don't know how it is to play
when there's all these flags yeah I will
say that you know stopping the game
definitely makes the game tougher you
know I like what I've flown smooth but
you know you have to get the calls right
though you know tell that guys is old
everybody to so it goes before it what
if I said offensive linemen had to wear
miniature boxing gloves and mittens so
they couldn't hold you is Jacksonville
back to me in Saxon ville
without a doubt you know I felt like you
know it's just a matter of time you had
to keep playing ball you know we you
know we just start to say the way we
wanted to but we had some good things
that we did or we're not you know this
was wasn't a good overall performance
from all of us but then once we got into
our groove the kind of get things going
and we stood up when I go yesterday we
still can play a lot better but you know
we're definitely got some things going
good what's the game plan against Marcus
Mariota what are you trying to make him
do making one-dimensional because of
2222 special you know I mean what he did
to us
you know the game before on television
when I was the Berenstain so you know we
want to shut him down
make it a one-dimensional you know at
the end zone I don't know
Louis another guy who there's a guy who
we respect a lot and what he was doing
catching bought at the backfield and you
know just being a playmaker form you
know we want to stop the reticular take
away the running backs like I'm
one-dimensional and then from there we
knew where our pass rusher in our
secondary man you know we make tens
one-dimensional would be tough to beat
what did you know about gardner minshew
do you know him
I'm a football fan so I mean I've seen
them you know I sent a play last year
when he's in college a couple times just
because I like watching football and you
know when we drive to the mostly okay
you know he seems like it's a kid you
know he comes in and he has a
unbelievable swagger tone you know you
have to you know you have to admire the
way he comes to work every day just with
a smile on his face you know like every
on top of the world living it living his
best life and then you know seeing them
coming to the game and then playing at a
high level you know I mean he's earned
the respect of everybody that locker
room and I he's a guy who comes in with
his head down ready to work but also
joins himself brings a lot of energy and
he's been playing great for us he's a
little goofy well no no rookies aren't
that goofy like that now just have you
been around when he does his stretching
with his jockstrap on or naked you
confirm it I have not got to witness
that you know which is probably a good
thing what is this strangest things you
strangest thing you've ever seen in
locker room no name Oh a lot of
different things by kid I think that's
not my head but you know I mean you get
around a lot of different personalities
and you know people do different things
so it's definitely the locker room is
the interesting place what do you make
of the Jalen Ramsey situation how does
this end I have no idea you know I know
one thing is I I join playing with him I
think y'all you know he makes us better
but the other day I understand how it
goes you know
and things happened and you know yet to
be able to handle whatever comes so you
know feelings of generated or if he
studies and I was out of my control
you know but I'm making sure that you
know I try to keep the guys prepared and
ready to go locked in I'm you know the
next assignment but you're you're a
veteran I mean you just turned 1933 like
what role can you play with Jalen Ramsey
I mean I try to be a good leader
and I trying to communicate and you know
at the end of the day we've had
countless conversations over the last
couple of years you know and I know he
respects me a lot you know but the
biggest danger is just you know the
community and you know given the best
advice I can give them you know I mean
we have James Irwin and you know prepare
for the short week this week so it was a
much conversation about all of that you
know more about trying to win this
ballgame especially being down over two
so you know and then navigate a little
through daybreak so see how things play
out but uh you know he's a guy that was
on the field he makes us better
he's Jalen Ramsey a Jaguar on Monday
you're gonna find out a little bit
before I do but yeah I got my doubts
about it I did you know Tom Coughlin's a
hardliner and so his coach Marone so I
don't know I get feeling that Jalen is
was in uniform but you know he might
have been elsewhere last night as well
yeah I know that been this one week and
all the stuff going on going on I mean I
was I was very impressed with my guys
you know locking in and playing good
ball because you distracted what
everything that's going on we locked in
and played football
well you had a huge game last night
three sacks you raised $18,000 for
feeding Northeast Florida Food Bank last
night with each of those sacks you got
eighty four and a half sacks in your
career if you get to a hundred are you a
Hall of Famer I mean that would be nice
you know you play this game trying to be
the best in the best be the best of the
best and I mean I salt in the goal but
in a day you know I mean
join it you know can't worry about on
you know in accolades everything else
man I gotta just stay locked him in the
moment
hey congrats on the win and enjoy the
days off you got Denver coming up in a
little more than a week so thanks for
joining us glaze it's a class Campbell
Jags defensive end for more game Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]